during my time at university i completed
quite a few degrees i started enrolling
myself in a bachelor of philosophy with
minors in history in arts and in
economics next i wrote myself in a
bachelor of business administration both
at the university of munich lmu actually
completed this one in five semesters the
bachelor philosophy in the regular six
semesters during my bachelor and
business administration i also spent a
semester abroad at bocconi university in
milan
then during the middle of my bachelor i
enrolled myself in a bachelor of laws at
the distance university haagen in the
later completed that as well at the same
time i wrote myself at the cdtm program
which is a joint institution of the tu
munich the technical university munich
and the lmu munich and i graduated with
an honors degree in technology
management i then later enrolled for
master in accounting and finance at
london school of economics and then of
course in the end i also completed my
mba at insead so in this video i'm going
to talk about exactly that how did i do
that how did i study three bachelor
degrees in parallel and i will also
share a couple of tips if you intend to
do something similar as well and the
last will reflect whether this actually
helped myself in my career or not so
let's get out and let's get going it's a
beautiful weekend here in munich today
we're visiting some of the munich lakes
so let me share a couple of
considerations that you have in your
mind when thinking about starting
several bachelors at the same time the
first is the selection of the university
here especially some private business
schools might not even offer different
degree programs in many private business
schools you can indeed only study
business the second limitation is that
often also the regulations of university
sometimes do not allow you to be
enrolled in several degree programs at
the same time here in germany it's
especially the big public universities
that often a little bit more lenient i
studied at the university of munich for
my first two bachelor degrees in the
third distance university so make sure
that the choice of university supports
the study programs that you want to
study indeed second make sure to combine
subjects that actually compatible with
each other in regards to the examination
structure that they have here one
advantage of comparing for instance a
business degree with liberal arts is
that business studies usually are very
heavy on exams so at the end of the
semester you will usually have an exam
period where i had lots of exams and on
the other hand for liberal arts there
are usually almost no exams at all that
examination structure looks the way that
you will write lots of essays lots of
written course work that you need to
prepare and these will often need to be
written during the semester so i did the
advantage that at the end of the
semester i was able to just study for my
business exams and didn't need to do
that much work during the semester for
this degree and during the semester then
and indeed had the time to focus for the
philosophy degree and make that work
third thing strategically about the
semester abroad that you might do so i
did a semester abroad at bocconi
university in milan and that actually
helped me to finish my business degree
earlier because i indeed finished my
bachelor in business in five semesters
instead of six semesters including the
bachelor thieves and one of the main
ways i did this is that in milan and
bocconi i wrote a full exam period and i
was able to carry over many of the exams
that i wrote in milan towards my
business degree and then once i came
back from milan i also completed a full
exam period in the same semester in
munich as well because there the exams
happen a little bit later than the exams
in milan and still a time couple of
weeks to prepare for these exams so
pretty much did the course work of two
semesters and only one semester and this
that enabled me to for instance in my
last semester complete an internship at
mckinsey this enabled me then to fully
focus on my bachelor thieves in
philosophy and semester number six many
students actually extend their studies
if they do a semester abroad in my
experience if you set it up the right
way can actually help you to complete
your studies in a quicker way let's now
talk about time management because this
is a topic i quite often get questions
on how did you manage to do all this how
did you manage your time in the past
already created a video about this topic
i will link it somewhere above here let
me also know in the comments if you
would like to have more content on that
i think the basic insight is the time
management in these types of situations
isn't even that challenging if you just
have the pressure that on this day you
will have the exam you will make sure
that the day before the exams you will
do the study if there is a course work
and essay that you need to submit you
will make sure that in the days before
you will write this essay because what
would you do instead and the truth is
most people would just in the evenings
watch netflix hang out maybe with some
friends and so on which of course can
also be fun but personally i found that
i can still do lots of these things i
still had lots of fun was going out with
friends but a couple of asses every
semester a couple of exams in the end of
the semester this is still very much
possible if you just have the deadline
the pressure another smallest force to
put in the time to not fail so was all
the effort really worth it let's look at
that from three perspectives first to
get my very first job in consulting at
mckinsey second for my mid to long term
career development and third just for my
very personal life first for mckinsey
did this help me to get into mckinsey
and very frankly i'd say yes it did help
me i think it was something a little bit
special that i did to study both
business philosophy law surely not all
the other business candidates did that i
think especially when you study business
it's important to have a special spike
something special that other people are
not necessarily doing for me i'd say
that was one of the factors of course do
not know how my profile would have been
assessed if i wouldn't have done that
but for sure that did not hurt me second
how did this help me with my roads after
mckinsey and you frankly i didn't think
it had that much of an effort more or
less all the things i did after mckinsey
were very much based on my network
personal relationships that i had up to
this job frankly i'm not sure if i will
ever apply to any job again in the
future wherever just classically with a
cv in a code way apply somewhere i think
that's probably true independent from
your degree i think the further you
advance in your career the less
important your actual degrees will be
that you may be accomplished attained
somewhere in the past i think at some
point it's just not that important
anymore i think it especially helps you
to get in to get that very first job and
third how do i assess this for myself
for my personal development for the
knowledge that i built and here frankly
starting with the business degree
spending a couple of years in management
consulting will be at least as effective
at starting completing a batchline
business so that's why it helped me of
course to get the context understand a
couple of things a bit better just for
that probably the timing consulting
alone would have done at least that much
for me myself second the philosophy
degree i think this very much shaped
just how i approach problems how i think
about problems i think it's just very
difficult also for myself to see how i
would approach things so i would see
things if i wouldn't have studied that
degree surely it helped me a lot to
develop my critical thinking it's very
difficult for me to assess how this
would have looked like if i wouldn't
have done that and third the law degree
this might be actually the degree where
i got the most practical value from
especially my roles after consulting
because directly after mckinsey i moved
into a mid-sized german retailer in a
restructuring role as a cto and i was
faced with lots of legal questions in
this position i did work together with
many lawyers at the time here this legal
basic understanding was insanely
important helpful to me and even now in
my current role in startup in the
management position in startup i'm also
facing level questions almost all the
time and it's really important helpful
for me to have this background of course
i'm not as qualified as a lawyer but at
least i know what they're talking about
i can assess whether what someone tells
me makes sense or not and this is
immensely helpful indeed so did you
study several degree programs in
parallel as well let me know about your
experiences in the comments i do hope
this maybe inspired some of you to do
similar things in the future as well if
you took away any value out of this
video at all please destroy the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe and turn on the
notification bell to stay up to date
with the content big big thanks to all
the members of the channel for your help
this is very much appreciated my name is
heineke already content every single
saturday here on the video so all the
best to you see you next week and bye